these three little holes in the ground
are meant to be Graves the Israeli
settlers who dug them even laid flowers
near a Palestinian bedin School a maab
and disturbing warning to this
Palestinian community in the occupied
West
Bank murder they want to kill us the
message is clear they would even murder
our children it's intimidation they want
us out during the interview two armed
settlers wearing military uni form
approach in a small off-road vehicle
they stop and film us as we film
them the attacks often happen at
night the Palestinian Community say the
attacks are led by this man seen here
armed and seemingly being protected by
Israeli soldiers after he walked into
the bedwin goat
pens he lives here at a settler Outpost
a couple of kilometers away
he bit me and another woman he asked us
to give him our phones The Other Woman
was holding her baby when he hit
her thead bin have lived here for more
than 50 years their livelihood depends
on these Green Pastures for their
animals a way of life that for
Generations has barely changed for
decades the bedwin were able to herd
their goats down into this field close
to an illegal Israeli settlement a
settlement they tell us is expanding in
this direction it would have been a
couple of weeks ago the bin say that a
group of Israeli settlers armed and
wearing military uniform came and put
these steel stakes in the ground now the
line of these Stakes runs for around 4
km in that direction it's clear evidence
that the settlers are trying to take
more
land we accompany sulan to the local
Israeli police station he and two of his
friends want to make formal complaints
suan says the settler leader purposely
ran over and killed 10 of his goats then
stole their carcasses the police
demanded we stop filming raised the
footage and insisted we
leave the next day we returned to the
Village to hear what the police said San
says he spent 9 hours at the police
station he says it often felt like they
were investigating him not the alleged
crime he was
reporting the police only care and come
when the settlers lie and complain about
us I filed an official Complaint to
protect myself it's like we have no
rights in the eyes of the Israeli police
it's like we don't exist in Israeli
law suman's complaint to the Israeli
police seemingly made no difference the
next morning the settlers are
back the next time this happens and you
play games shouts one masked man
carrying a rifle I'll call the police
and they'll take all your sheep
away this BN community living on
Palestinian land is being terrorized by
armed men apparently immune or
indifferent to Israeli or international
law Char stranford al jazer mad in the
occupied West
Bank
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jaaz